welcome to another episode on my channel
firm learning
my name is heinrich and as you know on
my channel i want to help you
to become successful in the first years
of your career
here today i'm once again back at my
university of munich
this is the place where i studied
business and philosophy
during my undergrad and the topic of
today's video
is private university versus public
university
private school versus public school and
the question is which
one is better is private university
really
worth the money is it worth the
investment
of your time of your effort and i want
to reflect on this
exactly here at my old university
because indeed
while i did my bachelor in munich in
parallel to that
i completed a semester abroad at bocconi
university in milan
which is a private business school and
then later continued
to do a master in finance and accounting
at the london school of economics
in london so indeed the question is
which one is better
this is what we're going to talk about
today so before we jump into the details
of the pros and cons of public vs
private universities
i first want to specify a bit more what
exactly i mean
by this public university because i know
that here there are significant
differences
also country by country especially also
on the wider regions
so for instance i know that for sure if
in a u.s context
you talk about a public university the
universities that there you would have
in your mind
are probably very different than what
you would talk about in for instance a
german
or broader european context because
indeed here in germany public
universities
like the university of munich are quite
good indeed
and indeed this is a trust similar in
many other european countries as well
so in the context of this video i will
rather talk about this more european
type of system
where while a public university might
not necessarily have the reputation
of some of the very best private ones
they're still considered to be good
and to some extent also competitive and
some of them even target universities
but we're going to talk about this
concept a bit more in a couple of
minutes
i will now talk about four aspects where
private universities potentially a bit
different
than public universities and the first
one is
the richness of experience and this is
now especially relevant when you compare
private
business schools to public big
universities
like for instance the university of
munich and for me one of the key reasons
why i decided to start my undergraduate
studies here in munich
compared to for instance also some
german private business foods that exist
for sure as well
was really the opportunity to study
different
types of subjects different types of
degree programs
and personally i did indeed study
business and philosophy
but even if you are not willing to
complete two full degrees
if you just enrolled in a business
program and then just take individual
lectures individual classes on some
other topics as well
for me this was one of the key parts of
the experience of studying in an
undergraduate degree
and this is of course often not really
possible
in a private business school maybe if
you compare this to the london school of
economics and political sciences which
is the full name of the school
there yes there were some other
opportunities but for instance at my mba
i only had the opportunity to take
business classes
while these were for sure high quality
and very interesting and relevant
business classes
there i missed this opportunity to go
beyond my
core subject same thing was through at
the university bocconi
which is indeed an italian business
school as well and this then also
translates just to the size and
magnitude of university
so here in munich 50 000 students are
studying
this comes with lots of extracurricular
activities
organizations other opportunities that
you could be part of
in parallel to study in university where
things like that exist as well in these
private schools these are often much
smaller
and by that also just the sheer amount
and opportunities of organizations
activities societies
that you can be part of is limited this
is at least what i strongly felt
next point i want to talk about is the
quality of the teaching the quality of
the education
that is being delivered to you and here
i'd assume that many people would argue
that yes the private universities
have an advantage and of course this
might also be the case
especially because due to the better
funding of the private universities
there you will often have smaller group
sizes instead of sitting in a class with
900 other students as i often experience
it here at the university of munich
in universities like jealousy where i
studied or bocconi in milan or the later
of course also the mba
the class sizes were significantly
smaller
contributing to a better learning
environment i'd say
and here now right now i'm standing in
front of the business faculty
where i studied here in munich and
indeed it was the case
that why the classes were often larger
especially the later
in the third fourth fifth sixth semester
of university
you had courses you had seminars where
then the group sizes were smaller as
well
so i wouldn't say it's this black and
white when you compare these two types
of universities
though indeed on average i would say it
is correct
that these interactions are richer are
in smaller groups
in the private universities but here i
also want to say that in general the
quality of the lectures the quality of
the teachings
this had not a lower quality munich here
it also had some excellent lectures
excellent classes delivered by excellent
professors
so this i'd say was rather similar
though again
quality of the groups smaller group
sizes this is really
what you get as a pro in this private
context
the next thing i want to talk about are
student fees
and indeed student fees are often one of
the first things that come to your mind
when you talk about these private
universities
and indeed this is of course true so
when i studied here at university of
munich
i almost paid no student fees at all
essentially studying at a public
university in germany
is for free so this is of course
different
to the private universities when i
completed my master in accounting and
finance in london
i paid over 20 000 pounds british pound
in student fees
and i recently checked again the web
page today it costs even over 30
000 pounds this is of course a crazy
amount and can be very
detrimental for other people trying to
study in this way
so how can you do this what can you do
to finance this
and indeed there are lots of
opportunities for scholarships
i would encourage you really to check
out scholarships that might be available
to you
i was privileged enough to pay at least
a significant portion of the total
student fees
with scholarship programs of course the
exact programs that are available to you
depend
on your country on the university on
your region so do this research
though my opinion also is if you really
want to do it if you have a dream
university where you want to study
there are ways to make it work i would
very likely
not not study at such a university only
due to the student fees there are often
ways to finance it
and indeed after you study at such
university especially if you study
something in the area of business
you will often have opportunities to
then also recoup remake the money
rather correctly after graduating at
least if you then also have the goal
to move into one of these high-paced
careers that then provide you with the
salaries that would also enable you
to pay back the student loans that you
might potentially take to finance this
the other question that of course people
have in mind when talking about
public versus private university is the
whole discussion of
target schools is the whole discussion
of whether or not
it really helps your career to study at
these
private schools potentially because they
are considered
a target school which is a school that
is a preferred university
for employers to hire from and indeed
now reflecting on my experience here i
think the first
insight is that you always need to
distinguish local target schools
from global target schools because the
university of munich
even though it is a public university
could be considered
a target school in germany right so this
university has the reputation
in germany that it is one of the leading
business schools and indeed all these
employers that we so frequently talk
about on this channel
like the mbb consulting firms mckinsey
bcg bane and so on
they do like to hire people from the
university of munich
and indeed i was hired for an internship
at mckinsey
when i was studying in the middle of my
bachelor here though the truth is also
probably if you go beyond germany if you
go beyond the country
very few people will really know the
university of munich so it is
a local target school and now you can
compare this to a school like the london
school of economics in the uk
in england this is of course university
which is probably well known
also far outside of the uk many people
in many other countries will know this
university so this is university
that might be considered an
international target school
and if you want this type of reputation
if you want to study at university
with a reputation that exceeds the
boundaries of your region of your
country
it might be worthwhile to go there as
well and yes of course in terms of
target schools
in terms of later potentially also
applying to an mba
or to other larger global firms this
might be helpful
though i would argue most of your career
ambitions
can very much be fulfilled with studying
at a
public university which is a local
target school as well
so i hope that these different
considerations these different
dimensions that i looked at are helpful
to you
if you are in the position to not ask
yourself whether you'd like to study at
a public or private university
but what is my personal conclusion what
is my reflection
on this question and personally i would
not have wanted to miss my time in
munich it was for me an extremely
remarkable
informative time indeed just also from
the cost perspective
given that the undergraduate degree
usually goes three to four years
now the need of having to pay student
fees for all this time
this is of course insane and it's
arguably whether you will
recoup this financial burden than later
in your job
though what i think could be the sweet
spot is to indeed do the undergraduate
degree
at a public university benefit from the
lower cost
from this very remarkable experience
that you get there
and then get for the private university
the master degree because the master
often is only one to two years
so the cost will be lower there you can
then get also all these benefits
without incurring all the cost this is
in the end how i did it and reflecting
on this it did make a lot of sense
for my personal career and also looking
back at some of my peers
many people followed a similar route and
it worked out quite well for them as far
as i can take
so now i'd love to hear from you what
are your experiences did you study at
the public
or private university if you studied at
a private university
what are your reflections was it really
worth your money i'd love to hear from
you
and indeed as you know every comment
that you leave below the video also
helps me with the algorithm
and indeed if you took any value out of
this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date on all my content i release
new videos
every single saturday and if you want to
see even more from me also follow me on
my instagram
my handle is firm learning i now want to
say thanks to all the members of the
channel
you're really making a great
contribution to the course of this
channel
thank you so much and to all the others
of you good weekend to you
hope you are having great days see you
back next saturday this is heine from
from learning
bye